hey guys dave rubin here that's right
I'm still Dave Rubin this is Rubin
report as you guys know we are making
the move to aura TV they are building me
an unbelievable set right now
so Larry King was nice enough to let me
use his studio today and the reason we
wanted to do some stuff with you guys
today is because I have doctor GAD sad
here he is professor of marketing at
Concordia University in Montreal Canada
and he's the Research Chair in
evolutionary behavioral sciences and
Darwinian consumption I don't really
don't use a teleprompter but I needed it
for that GAD how are you very good
yourself good good how first off GAD
said how was my pronunciation of your
last name it's Arabic
am i a desirable well God is a Hebrew
name okay and sad is an Arabic name but
most people can't say the guttural sound
and so just gets an extended a so yeah
I'm sad well I've heard you do it on
your own videos on YouTube and you don't
even do it with the guttural because I
don't want to intimidate the viewers so
a Hebrew first name Arabic last name
that's right so you must be very
conflicted I'm not I'm not I'm from
Lebanon yeah but of the Jewish faith
okay so the reason that I wanted to
bring you in and the timing of this
really is just perfect is because we
connected sort of in the last year and a
half or so on Twitter we find ourselves
often in the same Twitter wars with
people the atheists and the new atheists
and the far-left and the people on the
right and everyone that's always
battling on Twitter and we're usually on
the same side with rights and really
what started this whole thing was when
Sam Harris was on Real Time with Bill
Maher and he and Ben Affleck and Bill
got into a big fracas so let's take a
look at the clip and then we'll go from
there
sure so the other thing we want to talk
about of course is that you and I have
been trying to make the case I think I
have anyway that liberals need to stand
up for liberal principles this is what I
said on last week's show obviously I got
a lot of hate for it but all I'm saying
is that liberal principles like freedom
of speech freedom to practice any
religion you want without fear of
violence freedom to leave a religion
equality for women equality for
minorities including homosexuals these
are a liberal
suppose that liberals applaud for but
then when you say in the Muslim world
this is what's lacking then they get
upset yeah yeah well liberals have
really failed on the topic of theocracy
they'll criticize white theocracy look
criticize Christians they'll still get
agitator over the abortion clinic
bombing that happened in 1984 but when
when you want to talk about the
treatment of women and homosexuals and
free thinkers and public intellectuals
in the Muslim world I would argue that
liberals have failed us and the crucial
point of confusion yeah thank you well
the crucial point of confusion is that
that we have been sold this meme of
Islamophobia where every criticism of
the doctrine of Islam gets conflated
with bigotry toward Muslims as people
right that is it's intellectually
ridiculous even it gets to the person
who understands the officially codified
doctrine of Islam this is I think
actually well educated on this time I'm
asking you so you're saying if I
criticize that you're saying that
Islamophobia is not a real thing that if
you're critical of something what's not
a real thing when we do it but I'm not
denying that
certain people are bigoted against
Muslims as people that right and that's
a problem big of you but the gross it's
racist it's not it's but it's so it's
like saying those donate your shifty Jew
you're not absolutely not well we are
say you guys are saying if you want to
be liberals believe in liberal
principles like freedom speech like you
know we are endowed by our forefathers
and a little electric I'm going to
create no man we have to be able to
criticize bad ideas ok so that clip goes
on for about 10 minutes and I showed you
about 2 minutes right there and I think
Sam hit the point right at the end that
we have to be able to criticize bad
ideas and to me this I've seen a real
schism in people on the left now I'm
obviously on the left I stand for
liberal principles but this schism and
this idea that you can't criticize ideas
without somehow condemning a whole group
of people I know this is a big
point of contention for you so can you
walk us through that sure I don't I
don't think that people have difficulty
criticizing ideas I think it's a
specific idea right so I see it every
day in my exchanges on Facebook if I
criticize some Jewish practice I get
many many likes on Facebook if I
criticize some hick Republican senator
about his position on evolution I get
tons of likes but if I dare criticize
something about Islam I'll give you a
very quick example I put up a clip of a
Iraqi scientist an astronomer who was
arguing that the earth is flat as it
says so in the Quran yeah so I received
of course many of my Facebook friends
are academics I received from a white
sort of guilt-ridden academic from from
California and a note saying well ha
what why are you ganging up on these
folks so she wasn't offended by the fact
that this Iraqi scientist was holding it
astonishingly outrageous view she was
annoyed that I would actually point to
that yeah so why do you think people
have trouble making this distinction
it's very obvious to me as as an
outsider of this I look at I'm Jewish
but I look at the book you could say
whatever you want about the book and all
the awful things that are in the Old
Testament or the New Testament of the
Quran frankly I haven't really read any
of them I don't know their their books
their ideas why why do people seem
unable to detach those two things
because I think they're I think the the
the misinformation associated with the
idea that if you criticize Islam in
particular yeah you're bigoted because
Islam is a religion of brown people
right and so therefore they're simply
unable to decouple the criticism of a
set of tenets from the people who may
practice those tenets right so to me
Bill Maher sort of hid the maybe the
bigger point here which is that for
people on the left for liberals we have
to stand up consistently for liberal
principles which is certainly what I try
to do I stand up for women's rights and
gay rights and freedom of religion and
economic equality and all of those
things so is this where liberals have
really failed and the way they fail is
by invoking cultural and moral
relativism right so who are we to judge
that women in some faraway land their
clitorises are being cut right who are
we
to impose our cultural hegemony on other
folks and so this is how they're able to
still be liberal and yet not criticize
these one particular sets of beliefs by
invoking cultural relativism right so
there's a real disconnect in reality
there because in a in a weird way
liberals should be the most for helping
these piece alright because these are
the principles they believe in so how
much of this actually I really hadn't
thought in the slightest now but I guess
a lot of this we could sort of blame the
footsteps of george w bush for going
into the wrong war where now there's
this feeling in america like we
shouldn't do anything ever because we
did the wrong thing clearly in iraq and
now it's it's a far worse mess than even
before so some of the blame is on us
right but i mean how far do you go back
unfolding history until you find the
villain of your choice right yeah so for
example when we talk about the
israel-palestine issue people are always
able to unfold history until the
starting point that they feel happy to
have and then that's the point where we
start the clock right so where should we
start the clock on that one on this top
issue on israel-palestine yeah well
that's it's a whole other thing if we
could get into it if you want I think
the problem there is that you've got two
Abrahamic religions that hold very very
rigid positions and as long as it's
going to be lathe and wood religion it's
never going to be resolved so in a weird
way be so what you're saying is that
that liberals don't want to criticize
Islam because there's this idea that a
lot of Islamic people have brown skin
but there are plenty of moroccan jews
you're 11 east you right there are
plenty of Christians that are iraqi
though there's not that many anymore but
so even that in a weird way you could
say that that's actually bigoted that
that that concept is bigoted how do you
as a dark-skinned do you feel about that
well i usually am able to get away with
a lot more stuff precisely because i
invoke the fact that i have dark skin
the fact that I'm from the Middle East
and I used this victimology game against
the social justice warriors yeah
basically saying hey be careful don't
you criticize me because then you'd be
engaging it
I refer both aerophobia fascism I
actually did the
privilege score and I scored off the
charts in my non privilege Wow I'm
untouchable
you're completely on